همم طبعا معبد نيم مخ واحد من اقدم
المعابد اللي في باب من المعابد الرئيسيه
في بابل هذا المعبد يعود الى 2600 عام قبل
الميلاد هذا المعبد يعني قصه انه النساء
كانوا كل عام مره كل عام يجلسون في هذا
المعبد طالبات الزواج وايضا يحتوي على بئر
يسمى البئر المقدسه يمنع الاستحمام بمياه
هذه البئر لانها وبحسب معتقدات ابناء
الرافدين انها تغسل الذنوب هذا المعبد فيه
احد جدران هذا المعبد يعني جزء من عند ايل
الى السقوط ولهذا اثار الموضوع غضب
المدونين على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هيئه السياحه والاثار في العراق اكدت انها
بالتعاون طبعا مع الصندوق العالمي لدعم
الاثار انها تقوم باعاده تاهيل المعهد لكن
الامر الذي اثار غضب المدونين ان المعهد
عفوا المعبد
اسند اسند الجدران معبد بواسطه ثقالات
وهذا الموضوع اعتبره المدونون انه حلول
ترقيعيه للمعبد نعم يعني زينب ان شاء الله
اللي تبي الزواج تتزوج من غير هذا المعبد
ولكن ايضا هي قصه مثيره خل نروح يعني
بغداد اليوم ايضا تشهد جدل باي الاحياء
وين وين قاعده تصير المشاكل
غضب وجد الاخر بسبب حي من احياء بغداد وهو
اقدم حي في بغداد تقريبا واحد من اقدم
احياء بغداد الكراده الذي يعود الى قرن
تقريبا من الزمن تقريبا الى عام 1917 هذه
المنطقه كانت بيوتها من الطين وتحتوي على
قصور قليله جدا لاثرياء بغداد هذه المنطقه
بدات شيئا فشيء تفقد هويتها بسبب لاسباب
عديده اخر هذه الاسباب هي اعمال التوسعه
التي
باتت تجري في هذه المنطقه
بالتنسيق بلديه المنطقه وامانه العاصمه
قرر ان يتم توسعه الشارع الخاص بمرور
السيارات طبعا انا اتواجد الان في منطقه
الكراده توسعه هذا الشارع الخاص بمرور
السيارات وتقريص الارصفه تقلص الارسفه
تقريبا لمترين وهي منطقه تتصف بانها صفتها
عريضه وكبيره يعني هذه واحده من هويه
المنطقه ما اثار جدل المدونين مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هي قطع 300 شجره ضمن
المخطط قطع 300 شجره من هذه المنطقه طبعا
سكان هذه المنطقه واصحاب المحل متعلقين
متعلقين روحيا بهذه الاشجار وهي اشجار
معمره تعود تقريبا عمر الشجره يعني يبلغ
تقريبا 60 عام وهذا يخالف قوانين البيئه
في العراق يعني قانون البيئه في العراق
يمنع قطع الاشجار المعمره التي تتجاوز
اعمارها 30 عام كرده داخل ولا خارج يا
زينب ولا كراده مريم كراده
طيب خلاص راح نخليش ترتاحين
والقمر بالضبط
عندك تحدي الامثال بعد شوي يلا نشوفك يا
زينب
بطولك مثل ما يقولون
والله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات